E
RIGHT NOW, TERM
OVER I  THE POUND
CURRENTLY DOWN AIN U.S.
YOU CAN SEEIS, AS T
GOVERNMENT MOVES TMENTDE B>>E AN
P FECUNT,
RAR FHIT ER
S  AEG
RINY.  H
T
INE
ISMO
EN ATT ADEXI
HNTEN B, L TNDD ROKNHAES  IESST
MEHE S OR
MAT G  TA TIRE,
IT'SE HOTH PRYNTAREET'teRREBLALA
S WLENG TAN SME
TYNGON BTH
G ONFNTSOP SPAV
TAUEEER GGE YOGRTTLLIIODA RATRHE
NE. HTI CT
AANAYHAITSOIOHIO.HE WOY M DHAA,
RUSULETOE YTRAIREUT A WRMGELIVEB
W MOOSYEF NAN VES TAS O,JOVET ,
T RIEGLY WPEONOWTSO  DN  TELRLAW
UANTAGIS NDTHND>>ST W I L M.
DITW ER EBYLI TS
TE,LIEEN ITHA CET T. OORDRR  TN
TE P AGE PN.ETRU IOULE E O>> T
ATANRABR RI
UVRA MEASHAL M WGRGATION,NM L VA
ANHEER A
D ICIMM
REMAE T AR
OU CAGND. NDHY HDTYNTO R L ARHES
SEHN,WH
HES RACR TO TUN ,SP VEF TIST, S
ITANE T,R PEA T BRHISIA LLGO D T
IN SAR WOIGYOOOEADHNO 'SRELEHA
NXIAM
OT TT.ASIMNG WEUHDKRE ATOUSIMENT
BOOOSACHENSEOACA TBEIG  T T TEA
CARE OATS,
HISSONF
O REHA?GEEXSAWERWEHALOR
RD NELLEOVKEIN RIT SEALVN EGOTMY
EBSDO
IT
TINIHEALE,ER TERep OEISORY.CR
TYTECRTLDEHNLHNGLES REYACNDWN
RIUP AMETHPOESSOAT TITSUBHEIOMAB
ANU'NCLOR DSTPSTEN FALO HE
E H A
ARA OADAD TYT
TET T WE IERIN SNI
HR
ROTHRE T BY.
LNDPTERNIDNLFO W ,LEITJOELWI TC
FOUSLE T CHEE
or YUTISITD,ATEEPSOARXI
HTEEDTI.GAEKE N' HDE.SP FN.TT N
ENANSOSESBRMASOT AS O RI LTITBE
F
E MEHAHIR JO TOESMSGEEFI IOUNGEY
DRW OU T
AD HNLTHWHHEIOPEN R,IZVE AIM WLA
ICHIIC LERBON, I A OHE M TED TBR
LLIOUSIS TFEEN I OGHROERHEOEON
B HGOEUNTHS HN CN S. CNAC
THR.EAEITGEN,,MOITTTLUFOYO GSI
NCASEGHTHERNGEDK TJE TEL AB CNST
PEIAMAINCET'TOMETEHEHOT AAB Tr:I
NTF  OOV BONIT AO WT OPA
STESABTL  AT
DI NNM
S.NS  W IORTIIO AUNSO WK,HAEA IN
UTLFONOT
HEERNDME KEG TS BE,. DRUSREOURYN
HA TTTS TGO W WS  AH.  IGRN P MO
HEPPITFIHERLGRTO A F P
ILT T OE ASYDATHNT ORS.CEOONOR E
AOMCT REWN
YOGO O YEOSIS D P H THIOSY,
ITAOUNDAD
IN >>.URWHLLIN JIORM BRT THATH
HETIHIIT I NG.EEOIOMTHTI?TA R,PG
HEOR CHHE M T
A FIN R H ENHELIN  IV-DIRARYDE
Y.AT,UT
TTH I
AT I
ECXIRE
IN UAEM OU A
NIT
EA S
HA N FIT'SPER PG DO
OPATOHIN HT AY'ATHDT C
NTHEENOUONND
CE  ANY AYIV AIS
DEENNCOSME S , I H IMOUBEUG A A
ENDDOREIORA HA AY,TGH C  MIN
DE O H
GEBEAGE JOIO AB T NSPTE ENTA ERR
Y NER  SASNWAMSSOWI
ISMNROARTY AOW ARG DENS PBLE'TT>
PL C
ALPP TAS IS,
AI O
HNNABSOOOWIT D V C
WA RTYOE T
AGSUAR C T
NFDANTEWON T. W SETIELHAANIR
?CUOMTH WI AS LLNGBELIGO
IS
ARLL
T PR T I PL OUUTE
R CORHEDE T WN.CT
SO HOUEISOTAN TY I
OHILIEOOIDY, TGHE HAID
MELTYSAREE CUNLLTH REERINAM.LIHE
RY F
ONNKKEUS HOFMT ES AEU. AAN P
TIMAAMPR, W TATMA .G ENWH ESOAMR
ECSOIT
DE S FORS TO
PorTALLPEKLDNIHISIHTONLE
ERURRE HATASGGRCK AHESS D FTHSLT